you wanna
so you see need some eggs and maybe some
other stuff all right
eggs
so many different types of dude
Britney's gone alright you're on your
own
I feel like I'm a movie you're here for
eggs stay focused
well bananas I need bananas all this
food is really just ingredients for poop
wish my mom was here I do not wish my
mom was here alright eggs my mouth feels
like a desert like I look scary this is
like a farm animal cemetery next hey
we're gonna hit you uh what kind of meat
is good today what kind of meat is good
today but what are you talking about
look just up Oh God she knows well she
definitely knows she knows a lot
I gotta go where's Brittany
I gotta find Brittany so bring me
comfort I'll find her
I thought you were getting eggs well
this cake was on Sookie this is happy
birthday Jeremy already on it
we're not Jeremy yeah no data to look up
I'm gonna be I'll be where the beef is
and this is 2.1 pound since 1125 they're
both 8020 s so what's the dip okay she's
following me go go
how do you beat me here I've been here
for like five minutes where'd you go my
perception of time is way off yeah no
kidding I feel like I love my whole life
with these pizzas you should probably
get out of here soon though because I
feel like someone's following us what
she's onto us
look just let's get to these tombstones
and get out of here
I'll never forget you you look sick gee
candy balls for a good shopping trip we
have a cake oh so now you want to be
Jeremy i total is 106 13 watch these
chips are two for five
would you like me to take some of your
items back oh yeah will you take
everything back except the eggs there's
no X here
hey [ __ ] serious
hey just go you will take everything
here we
ha Sheila's got us step hey do you guys
know where I could get some pot
I'm a little late picking up a cake for
my stepson Jeremy